[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zu einer
premiere wir senden das erste mal aus
unserem neuen studio und norbert lehmann
ist auch dabei für den sport ein schöner
und auch von mir
zentrales thema auch heute die
flutkatastrophe aufräumen im funkloch
ohne strom noch immer müssen in den
katastrophengebieten viele menschen
abgeschnitten von der grundversorgung
klarkommen ein nie da gewesene
überwachungsskandale so nennt der
deutsche journalisten-verband die affäre
pegasus auch ungarn soll mit der späh
software regierungskritiker überwacht
haben countdown in die freiheit oder ins
chaos ab heute darf in england clubs
wieder getanzt werden und auch sonst
fallen fast alle coroner regeln weg
obwohl die fallzahlen steigen
die akute gefahr in den meisten
hochwassergebieten ist vorbei der schock
nicht langsam erst wird deutlich was
alles kaputt ist und wie lange der
wiederaufbau dauern wird
besonders schwer getroffen hat es den
kreis ahrweiler im norden von
rheinland-pfalz 117 tote wurden hier
bislang geborgen 170 menschen werden
noch vermisst
auch am tag fünf nach dem unwetter gibt
es an vielen stellen keinen strom
trinkwasserleitungen sind zerstört und
die reparatur der gasleitungen könnte
monate dauern
susanne gelhard berichtet
auf dem historischen marktplatz von
ahrweiler müssen sie mit primitivsten
mitteln zurechtkommen
auch am tag fünf nach dem hochwasser
strom ist noch gar nichts da wasser
moment auch noch gar nichts passiert
alles ausgepumpt aber eine versorgung
ist auch wenig die straßen sind noch
immer kaum passierbar ein problem viele
gasleitungen sind beschädigt durch den
gasversorger ist er die gasleitung
abgestellt worden
daher ist halt keine gefahr mehr also
wir haben auch da mit selbst gas nichts
zu tun aber wirkt sich auf die leute aus
bei keine heizung funktioniert kein
warmes wasser in bad neuenahr hat das
thw eine trinkwasseranlage installiert
um den menschen wenigstens notdürftig zu
helfen
an eine gesicherte versorgung ist noch
lange nicht zu denken
stunde produzieren
die prüft trupps des landes sind
inzwischen unterwegs zu einer ersten
schadensaufnahme die b9 zentrale
verkehrsachse durch rheinland pfalz
wurde bei sind sich stark unterspült und
droht jetzt ganz einzustürzen
die gefahr ist groß deswegen sind wir
seit freitag ständig auch die brücke an
vermessen um zu schauen ist noch
bewegung drin oder nicht
und der nächste schritt ist ein
kontrollierter abriss brücken strassen
versorgungssysteme überall entlang der
aare ist die infrastruktur völlig
zerstört milliardenschäden
es wird das land immens fordern und
jetzt ist schnelligkeit gefragt wir
müssen ja hier in den herbst in den
winter dann wieder funktionierende
gasleitungen funktionierende heizungen
und vor allen dingen in kürze auch
funktionierende wasserversorgung haben
bis dahin wird es wochen monate
vielleicht jahre dauern
bobby cherry an ist für uns in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler was ist im moment das
wichtigste für die betroffenen um
voranzukommen
wir haben grunde brauchen die menschen
das was in teilen schon da ist also
kipplaster schlamm pumpen aber davon
viel viel mehr
wir haben hier so ein paar straßenzüge
gesehen die sehen mittlerweile halbwegs
normal aus soweit man das eben sagen
kann aber eben auch straßen und plätze
auf denen sich immer noch meterhoch der
müll stapelt
die bundeswehr hatte heute im ort einen
pool aufgestellt und hat dann wasser aus
der ah in diesem pool gepumpt damit die
menschen zumindest ein bisschen wasser
zum saubermachen haben denn so langsam
trocknet der schlamm hier in den straßen
und in den häusern wird steinhart und
ohne wasser bekommt man den nicht weg
wir haben heute gesehen wie das thw von
der a seite da hinten ein
telekommunikationskabel durch die ah
hier in den stadtteil ahrweiler gelegt
hat um internet und telefon wieder zum
laufen zu bringen also tag fünf nach dem
hochwasser und es fehlt immer noch an
den ganz elementaren dingen dankeschön
für diese eindrücke kriterium war dass
wir bleiben im landkreis ahrweiler und
blicken nach mai schoss der kleine
weinort es nach wie vor kaum zu
erreichen
auf straßen und gleisen türmen sich
tonnen von geröll nina kurschilgen und
volker check wer hier schnell helfen
will der muss aus der luft kommen denn
micros ist weitgehend von der außenwelt
abgeschnitten nur holprige
wirtschaftswege nichts für schweres
gerät mit dem man die ortsdurchfahrt
räumen könnte auch bürgermeister
hubertus kunst kann den moment nicht
vergessen als sie vor dem wasser
flüchteten
das dach das dachte auf den putz gehauen
die haben wir in die dachrinne gesetzt
kein wasser kein strom die helfer haben
100 liter kanister mitten im ort
abgeladen allerdings kein trinkwasser
an der arge wegen
kaputt einige hoteliers haben bereits
gesagt dass sie nicht mehr wieder
aufmachen
in der kirche ein nachschublager essen
kleidung medikamente in der sakristei
nebenan impfen die ärzte gegen korona
der bürgermeister will lehren aus dem
unglück ziehen
der blick nach vorn mit zuversicht und
sorge in einer zeit die allen meisters
und den anderen überschwemmungsgebieten
viel abverlangt nach nordrhein-westfalen
dort können die anwohner an der
steinbachtalsperre im kreis euskirchen
aufatmen die gefahr eines dammbruchs
scheint erst einmal gebannt die menschen
können zurück in ihre häuser
rund 100 kilometer nordöstlich im schwer
getroffenen altena ist das aufräumen in
vollem gange jan hofer berichtet alles
was sie hatten steht nun als sperrmüll
vor ihren häusern auch dimitra grube aus
alten erlebt jetzt in einem rohbau
sortiert das wenige was ihr geblieben
ist ihr mann ihre beiden kinder und sie
müssen hier trotzdem weiterleben
irgendwie dürftig ssten sachen in der
küche gebrauchen
oder brauchen backofen ein herd ein
kühlschrank um eben das tägliche leben
weiter fortzusetzen
hier vielleicht noch ein paar stühle
einem tierschutz ein bisschen überlebt
dass man wo essen kann aufatmen dagegen
an der steinbachtalsperre die gefahr
eines dammbruchs ist hier erst mal
gebannt bundesinnenminister seehofer und
der nordrhein westfälische
ministerpräsident laschet sind gekommen
um sich ein bild von der lage zu machen
die massive kritik am katastrophenschutz
sei zu spät und zu zögerlich gewarnt
worden weist seehofer zurück ich möchte
keinen zweifel daran lassen
dass diese föderale struktur im
bevölkerungs und katastrophenschutz
richtig ist und zwar seit vielen
jahrzehnten
wir sollten daran nicht rütteln
zentralismus verbessert wir gar nichts
in denen von der überflutung betroffenen
gebieten dagegen gibt es anwohner die
unzufrieden sind mit dem
katastrophenschutz und fragen stellen
steinbachtalsperre der damm china
vollständig in ordnung zu sein zumindest
nicht 100% hinein wundert es mich dass
man sie hat so volllaufen lassen obwohl
ja bekannt war dass eine unwetterzone im
anmarsch
das wusste man nicht erst drei tage
vorher bei vielen liegen die nerven
längst blank angesichts des ausmaßes der
zerstörung
mindestens 160 tote warum sind so viele
menschen gestorben solche fragen werden
jetzt lauter gestellt wurde ausreichend
gewarnt per app oder sirene hat die
zusammenarbeit zwischen den
einsatzkräften funktioniert aus der
katastrophe müssen lehren gezogen werden
an seinem stern in den trümmern in der
zerstörung arbeiten sie immer weiter
feuerwehr polizei thw sanitäter soldaten
kämpfen in der katastrophe seit anfang
an zu diesem anfang gibt es immer mehr
fragen die drängender werden direkt nach
der flut als die hilfe so
überlebensnotwendig war gab es große
probleme berichten die einsatzleiter
schon früh bei unseres der digitalfunk
komplett ausgefallen
das handynetz ist komplett ausgefallen
so dass wir im moment würde aber analog
von komplett die einsätze abwickeln
der digitalfunk eingeführt ab 2013 in
deutschland ziel ein bundesweit
einheitliches netz für retter und helfer
schnell sicher doch genau das hat
mancher orts überhaupt nicht mehr
funktioniert helfer konnten sich nicht
mehr erreichen nicht mehr abstimmen ein
polizist spricht gegenüber dem zdf von
völlig unkoordinierten einsetzen leichen
konnten offenbar erst nach vielen
stunden geborgen werden auch weil der
funk nicht mehr da war
der ministerpräsident von nrw unterwegs
mit dem bundesinnenminister bestätigt
heute massive schwierigkeiten mit dem
digitalfunk es gibt offenkundig
handlungsbedarf
wir haben das problem dass die
stromversorgung ausfiel und damit auch
die mobilfunkbetreiber erschwert wurde
und dazu noch funkmasten zerstört wurden
natürlich dies alles zusammen hat selbst
für die sicherheitskräfte die
kommunikation erschwert auch die
probleme mit dem funk die kommunikation
in der krise müsse nun aufgearbeitet
werden heißt es auch das wird wohl lange
dauern
im südosten bayerns können die menschen
etwas aufatmen der starke regen hat
aufgehört
im berchtesgadener land hat das große
aufräumen begonnen
in schönau am königssee sind besonders
schwere schäden zu beklagen
große teile der berühmten bob und
rodelbahn dort wurden zerstört
entspannung in passau donau und inn
stiegen nicht so stark an die
überflutungsgefahr ist vorerst gebannt
wenn sie den betroffenen helfen wollen
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat
ein spendenkonto eingerichtet die iban
lautet de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf hochwasser deutschland
weitere informationen finden sie unter
spenden zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite
8 190 und gleich hier im anschluss folgt
auch heute ein zdf spezial zur lage in
den hochwassergebieten anderes thema
jetzt die software pegasus kann von der
ferne auf handys gespielt werden um sie
abzuhören
der israelische hersteller sagt sie
werde nur im kampf gegen den terror
eingesetzt
doch offenbar wurde sie weltweit auch
von autoritären staaten genutzt um
hunderte von regierungskritikern zu
überwachen
das berichtet ein internationales
recherche netzwerk wolf christian
ullrich hat details der vorwurf ist
ungeheuerlich unliebsame journalisten
anwälte und oppositionspolitiker von
ungarischen behörden abgehört mit hilfe
von pegasus einer software die dafür
gedacht ist handys von kriminellen und
terroristen auszuspionieren ein albtraum
für den journalisten pany scharbeutz der
selbst betroffen ist ein halbes jahr
lang war das software programm von
pegasus auf meinem handy
sie konnten meine videos und bäder sehen
haben das mikrofon eingeschaltet und
konnten gespräche aufnehmen
die israelische firma nsu bietet die
spionage software international staaten
zum kauf an um terroristen und deren
pläne zu entlarven hat sicherlich alles
dafür getan ein solides und robustes
programm zu schaffen
gegen das man nichts tun kann die opfer
merken gar nicht dass sie opfer eines
lauschangriffs sind zu den kunden zu
berichten heute europaweit profilierte
investigativ reporter zählen eu staaten
aber auch autokratische und
diktatorische wie marokko als abidjan
oder saudi arabien
letztere gingen damit gegen unliebsame
journalisten und menschenrechtler vor
auch der eu staat ungarn horch auf diese
weise regierungskritiker aus wir
beobachten die lage in ungarn seit
vielen vielen jahren mit sorgen weil wir
wirklich einen schleichenden
systematischen abbau der pressefreiheit
erleben heftige kritik heute von seiten
der eu
wenn sich diese berichte als richtig
herausstellen dann wäre das komplett
inakzeptabel
es ist gegen jede regel zur
pressefreiheit in der eu ungarische
regierungsvertreter sagen heute die
datensammlung sei ihnen nicht bekannt
sollte es dennoch stimmen geriete der
ungarische rechtsstaat immer mehr unter
die räder
neues gibt es auch in sachen corona
fangen wir an mit den ansteckungen in
deutschland da geht die zahl weiter
langsam nach oben
beim rk wurden binnen eines tages 546
neue infektionen mit dem virus gemeldet
das sind 222 mehr als vor einer woche
eine person starb mit oder ancona die
sieben tage incidents stieg von genau 10
auf 10,3
in england liegt die inzidenz bei 426
trotzdem hat die regierung johnson heute
den tag der freiheit ausgerufen
seit mitternacht gelten dort kaum mehr
corona beschränkungen weder masken
pflicht noch abstandsregeln nicht nur
wissenschaftler fürchten jetzt eine neue
welle andreas stammen hat mehr countdown
in die freiheit schlag mitternacht
fallen hier die korona beschränkungen
die ersten partys nach 16 monaten
so groß die sehnsucht solange die
schlange keine abstandsregeln und masken
mehr endlich wieder so leben und
genießen wie ich es möchte kurve kein
problem ich bin geimpft hat meine maske
ich bin bereit
der tag des premiers dagegen beginnt in
unfreiheit nach kontakt mit dem corona
erkrankten gesundheitsminister sitzt
boris johnson in quarantäne und kündigt
aus der isolation am freiheitstag
einschränkungen an ende september wenn
alle über 18 doppelt geimpft sein können
wenn sie wollen wird voller impfschutz
notwendig sein um weiter nachtclubs oder
orte aufzusuchen an denen viele
zusammenkommen was sowieso bleibt die
isolations regeln die aktuell 1,7
millionen in quarantäne befördert haben
ein großteil durch die korona war app
weshalb krankenhäusern und betrieben das
personal ausgeht diese note dürfte
zunehmen die neue infektionen könnten
sich vervierfachen auf bis zu 200.000
täglich zwar ist mehr als die hälfte der
bevölkerung doppelt geimpft aber
millionen bleiben ungeschützt die
regierung verweist auf die niedrige zahl
der schweren verläufe rechnet dennoch
mit bis zu 200 toten täglich kritiker
halten das für verantwortungslos man
riskiere hunderttausende longo wird
fälle dass eine neue impfstoff
resistente variante entstehen
das einzige was ich zu sagen habe
scheiß auf die maske
[Musik]
regierung man zur vorsicht fordert
eigenverantwortung ohne den menschen
wirklich zu vertrauen
ein corona experiment mit chaos
potenzial erst mal voller öffnung voraus
bei explodierenden fallzahlen
in zypern hat es heftige proteste gegen
die korona politik des landes gegeben
teilnehmer einer demonstration griffen
den sitz eines fernsehsenders an
während der live nachrichten drangen sie
in das gebäude beschädigten das mobiliar
draußen flogen steine autos wurden in
brand gesteckt die proteste richten sich
vor allem gegen einen von der regierung
eingeführten speziellen corona
impfausweis ohne ihn darf man
beispielsweise nicht mehr ohne weiteres
in geschäfte und restaurants und jetzt
olympia norbert am freitag geht's los
mit den sommerspielen genau und dann
werden über 11.000 athletinnen und
athleten um die begehrten medaillen
kämpfen
das deutsche team das zählt 432
mitglieder die jetzt nach tokio nach und
nach in tokio angekommen sind und die
sich trotz aller corona beschränkungen
so richtig auf die wettkämpfe freuen
84 deutsche athleten landen am
montagmittag ortszeit in tokio
die basketballer tischtennis-ass
dimitrij ovtcharov beachvolleyball
olympiasiegerin laura ludwig und viele
andere für sie die in tokio ihre
wettkämpfe haben geht es direkt in die
sogenannte korona blase das
abgeschottete olympische dorf wenn man
doch wieder die ganzen sportler nationen
sie die häuser die mit flaggen hier
behang sind ist es schon was was ein
vorfreude auf die spiele macht besondere
spiele bei denen die sportler auch an
den wettkampfstätten beinahe unter sich
sein werden und die zuschauer fast alle
zu hause am fernseher und der deutschen
behindertensportverband der hat heute
die 134 athletinnen und athleten aus 18
sportarten für die paralympics nominiert
angeführt von weitsprung weltrekordler
markus rehm kämpfen zahlreiche
top-athleten um medaillen und wie immer
auch um mehr aufmerksamkeit für den
paralympischen sport die spiele finden
vom 24
august bis zum 5 september in tokio
statt
gestern formel 1 in silverstone lewis
hamilton touchierten max verstappen der
crash sein auto bleibt unverletzt
hamilton gewinnt das rennen danach
kritikern hamilton und empörung über
rassistische beleidigungen die der brite
erfuhr bei tempo 250 flieht max
verstappen aus der kurve auslöser für
den crash die berufung von lewis
hamilton der das rennen danach gewann
sein erster sieg nach zehn wochen
anschließend aber wurde hamilton in den
sozialen medien rassistisch beleidigt
was auch den in bezug auf das rennen
verärgerten kontrahenten red bull auf
den plan ruft wir mögen erbitterte
rivalen auf der strecke sein aber wir
stehen zusammen gegen rassismus soll red
bull racing in der gesamtwertung vielen
hamilton jetzt nur noch acht punkte auf
max verstappen
und was habe ich sport dankeschön und
wenn sie lust haben sollten dieses neue
studio noch ein bisschen genauer unter
die lupe zu nehmen einen blick hinter
die kulissen finden sie auf zdf heute
oder in unserer app dort können sie
virtuell das grüne studio erkunden oder
sich auch mal selbst an den
moderationstisch stellen kann ich sehr
empfehlen das wetter beruhigt sich
zunehmend morgen gibt es viel sonne
regen bleibt die ausnahme die details
hat gleich katja honnefer christian
sievers freut sich auf sie im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn danke für
ihr interesse
alles gute ideen und bis morgen wenn sie
mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend vor 24 stunden fielen noch
regen hier im berchtesgadener land im
laufe der letzten 24 stunden ist er aber
nach süden abgezogen was sich allerdings
auch sehen ist dass da neue wolken von
norden herangekommen sind die bringen
ein kleines bisschen nieselregen mit und
am nachmittag gab es auch einige schauer
in süddeutschland und mit diesen wenigen
schauern haben wir es auch in der nacht
hier im süden zu tun
sonst ist der himmel meist nur locker
bewölkt und die temperaturen sinken auf
werte zwischen 15 grad an der ostsee und
9 grad in den östlichen mittelgebirgen
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen in
norddeutschland meist so bei 20 22
vielleicht mal 23 grad im süden wird es
wärmer am oberrhein klettern die werte
bis 27 grad
morgen wird ein freundlicher tag sonne
und wolken wechseln sich ab und einzigen
schleswig holstein sind sie vor einigen
regen spritzer nicht ganz sicher und
auch zwischen dem oberpfälzer
bayerischen wald und alpenrand kann es
mal einen kleinen regenschauer geben
das ist dann aber wohl auch das letzte
mal dass regen gefallen ist in dieser
woche denn danach geht es sehr
sommerlich und sonnig weiter bei
temperaturen bis 30 grad
guten abend